والآن
في الضفة الغربية حيث انتقل جيل جديد من الفلسطينيين في بيت لحم
إلى الحواجز
التي تواجه جيلًا جديدًا من الجنود الإسرائيليين ،
شهد يوم الجمعة أعنف
المواجهات منذ سنوات بين
الشباب الفلسطيني
وقوات الأمن الإسرائيلية في جميع أنحاء
الضفة الغربية.
عدد القتلى
هنا منذ سنوات مع مئات الجرحى
شخص ما جُرح للتو
هنا في الواقع إنهم يقتربون في طريقنا ،
دعنا نتنحى جانبًا ،
إنها امرأة أصيبت
[موسيقى]
عدد لا يحصى من الحجارة التي ألقيت هنا
على مر السنين
بعد حساب عدد الإطارات
أحرق
عدد لا يحصى من قنابل الغاز المسيل للدموع التي
أمطرت على هذا الشارع ،
أطلق الجيش طلقات نارية بعد وابل
من الغاز المسيل للدموع في محاولة لتفريق
هذا الاحتجاج الذي هو مجرد واحد من
المتظاهرين الذين دخلوا
عبر الضفة الغربية
رسالة في هذا اليوم
للتضامن
مع رفاقهم الفلسطينيين في
القدس وغزة
وداخل إسرائيل
إذا أصيب أحدنا نحن  معهم
يقول هذا الشاب
الذي امتنع عن الكشف عن اسمه نحن
ندعمهم وكأن الشعب الفلسطيني كله
مصاب
ببيت لحم ، أحد سكان بيت لحم شارك شوكي عيسى
في احتجاجات في
شبابه ويشاركهم تلك الرسالة إنها وحدة
الفلسطينيين
مع صرخة لدينا حقوق.
لن نذهب إلى أي
مكان وسنواصل حتى نتخلص من
الاحتلال ونحصل على دولنا
المستقلة ويلات هذه الأرض المضطربة تنتقل
من
الأب إلى الابن بن ويدمان في
بيت لحم على الضفة الغربية.